♪ ♪
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, HAPPY
FRIDAY.
ALMOST SATURDAY.
SO BEING AN ADULT IS HARDER THAN
IT LOOKS.
TAKE IT FROM ME, I AM SOMEONE
WITH A HEART OF A CHILD.
WHICH I KEEP IN THE GLOVE
COMPARTMENT.
YEAH, UNCOMFORTABLE LAUGHTER.
THAT'S MY MIDDLE NAME.
>> YOU ARE PRETTY COMFORTABLE
WITH IT.
>> Greg: ACCORDING TO A NEW
SURVEY OF 2,000 RECENT GRADS,
81% OF THEM WISH THEY WERE
TAUGHT MORE LIFE SKILLS BEFORE
GRADUATING.
APPARENTLY DEMANDING AN END TO
MISS GENDER A NONBINARY STUDENTS
AND THE GEOLOGY DEPARTMENT
WASN'T ENOUGH PREP ON HOW TO PAY
BILLS WITHOUT SELLING YOUR
KIDNEYS ON CRAIGSLIST.
THAT WAS A LONG SENTENCE.
THE TOP SKILL THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
WISH THEY KNEW MORE ABOUT
INCLUDE HOW TO AND FAST AS WELL
AS LONG-TERM FINANCIAL PLANNING
WHICH IS WEIRD SINCE WHO NEEDS
LONG-TERM EVERYTHING IF THE
WORLD IS GOING TO END IN EIGHT
YEARS.
IF AOC IS CORRECT, YOU MIGHT AS
WELL TAKE UP SMOKING.
CRACK, METH, CRACK AND METH.
OTHER CONCERNS OR HOME
MAINTENANCE LIKE RESETTING A
WI-FI ROUTER, DOING LAUNDRY, AND
PERHAPS THE MOST IMPORTANT SKILL
OF ALL, UNCLOGGING THE TOILET.
SORRY, BUT WHAT IS TO LEARN
ABOUT UNCLOGGING THE TOILET?
FIRST OFF, FLUSHING THINGS THAT
AREN'T TOILET PAPER, EMILY.
>> COME GOD.
>> Greg: AND SECOND, BLAME IT
ON WHOEVER YOU ARE LIVING WITH.
BUT WHAT THIS TELLS YOU IS THAT
THESE LITTLE FABERGE EGGS HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF A PLUNGER.
WHEN I GREW UP, THE ONLY
HOUSEHOLD TOOLS BE USED WHERE
THE PLUNGER AND THE CAN OPENER.
AND GOD FORBID YOU MIX THEM UP.
SOMETHING TELLS ME IF YOU HANDED
THE PLUNGER TO A RECENT GRAD
THEY WOULD ATTACH A BLM SIDE TO
THE END OF THE HANDLE AND WEAR
IT LIKE A RUBBER SKULLCAP TO AN
ANTI-COPPER ALI.
THAT'S A GOOD LOOK.
OTHER FINDINGS WERE NOT LEARNING
HOW TO BUDGET.
ONE IN FIVE DON'T KNOW HOW TO
COOK.
THE SAME NUMBER CAN DO THEIR OWN
LAUNDRY, WHICH IS MIND-BLOWING.
HOW HARD IS IT REALLY TO DO YOUR
LAUNDRY?
JUST TAKE A SHOWER WITH YOUR
CLOTHES ON.
WHAT DO SEE DOES EVERY MORNING.
WHEN YOU GET UP THAT EARLY.
THEIR TOP FINANCIAL STRESS IS
BEING THERE DOLL NOT THEIR
MONTHLY RENT.
BUT THAT IS WHY STRIPPING WAS
INVENTED.
HOW DO YOU THINK I COULD AFFORD
MY GYM DUES?
SHAKY KNEES HIPS.
SO WHY ALL THE REGRET ABOUT
LOCKING REAL-LIFE SKILLS?
BECAUSE NOW THEY ARE IN REAL
LIFE.
AND COLLEGE HAD INDULGED A
JUVENILE FANTASY WORLD, THAT'S
LIKE CNN.
THEY CHARGED A FORTUNE TO TELL
YOU THE SKILLS THAT MADE THEIR
PARENT SUCCESSFUL ENOUGH TO
AFFORD TUITION.
GOD FORBID AMERICAN FLAGS.
IT'S FAR BETTER TO CONDEMN
CAPITALISM THAN A MINUTE YOU
BENEFIT FROM IT.
SO WHAT IS THE NUMBER ONE SKILL
IN LIFE THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE
THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE LEARNED IN
MY OPINION?
IT IS TO BE USEFUL.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
IT OVERRIDES EDUCATION AND
WEALTH.
IF YOU ARE USEFUL, YOU ARE
INDISPENSABLE.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE OF THE
ACADEMICS DEFINITION OF HEALTH,
THAT FAKE ACTIVIST BEHAVIOR.
NEARLY DURING THE ANTHEM,
BURNING DOWN A CITY BLOCK, DYING
YOUR HAIR BLUE, SCREECHING AT
COPS WHO MAKE LESS THAN YOUR
YOGA INSTRUCTOR.
NOW, THAT ISN'T BEING USEFUL.
THAT IS THE PHONY COLLEGE
DEFINITION OF IMPORTANCE.
INFLATING YOUR OWN EGO AND
MAKING USE OF THE CENTER OF
ATTENTION.
WHAT KIND OF CLUELESS NARCISSIST
ACTS LIKE THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S NO LIFE SKILL.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS A LIFE SKILL?
DIAL-IN CONFLICT DOWN INSTEAD OF
UP.
THAT IS USEFUL.
AS PARENT HOUSEHOLDS DWINDLE,
GOD IS THE EXAMPLE SITE FOR
PARENTS.
THE SKILL OF DIALING IT DOWN IS
LOST AND WOULD FILL THAT HOLE IS
THE WORST THING YOU COULD
IMAGINE.
THE MOB.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
MAFIA, THEY HAVE MUCH BETTER
FOOD.
I MEAN THE GAWKING HORDES OF
SOCIAL MEDIA WHO PREFER IT YOU
DIAL THINGS UP AND NOT DOWN.
SO WE HAVE A GENERATION EGGED ON
BY LIKES AND CLICKS WHO WHEN
THEY SEE SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENING, INSTEAD OF HELPING,
TURNING TO SCORSESE WITH A
SMARTPHONE.
AS COLLEGE DEPRIVES YOU OF LIFE
SKILLS, THE ONLY THING LEFT THAT
YOU CAN GRAB IS THIS EXHIBITION
ACTIVISM.
HAVE YOU EVER IMAGINE THE LIFE
OF AN ACTIVIST?
A MODERN ACTIVIST.
DID THEY EVER ENJOY A LEISURELY
DINNER?
NO.
DO THEY HAVE A COMFORTABLE GROUP
OF FRIENDS THAT THEY CAN BOWL
WITH?
NO.
COULD THEY HELP YOU OUT IN A
CLUTCH?
NO.
HOLY, I THINK I DESCRIBED TO ME.
THEY DON'T HAVE JOBS OR A CAR OR
EVEN WISDOM.
COULD THEY BE IN A RELATIONSHIP
WITH ANYONE BEYOND A THERAPIST
OR THE AMAZON DELIVERY GUY?
NO, WHO WOULD AGREE TO THAT.
WHERE WOULD YOU HONEYMOON?
EVEN MORE, THEY HAVE NO LIFE
SKILLS.
JUST RESENTMENTS, STUDENT DEBT,
AND HATE.
MAYBE THEY DON'T NEED LIFE
SKILLS BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
LIVES.
THE ELITE ACTIVIST CLASS PREFERS
IT THAT WAY.
THEIR GRIP IS DEAD AND WOKE ENDS
UP WITH AWAKE.
BUT ACADEMIA KNOWS THAT IF YOU
CAN'T SURVIVE IN REAL LIFE, YOU
WILL CLING TO THEIR BETTER
OFFERINGS.
HE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO CLOG A
TOILET BECAUSE YOU ARE JUST TOO
FULL OF [BLEEP].
[APPLAUSE]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS!
THE NATIONAL --
WHAT WAS THAT?
THE NATIONAL GUARD GETS AROUSED
WHEN THEY CALL IN THIS UNIT.
THE ONLY TIME HE GETS LEFT IS
FROM ASKING WOMEN TO DANCE.
WHEN SHE TALKS, BEN SHAPIRO
TELLS TO SLOW DOWN.
EMILY COMPAGNO.
AND FINALLY, HE SO HUGE WE USE
HIS SOCKS AS PARACHUTES, MY
MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND HOST OF AN
UPSET ON FOX NEWS, TYRUS.
I'M GLAD WE PUT ACID IN WATER
FOR THE AUDIENCE.
YOU CAN TELL.
SO PETE, YOU HAVE 30 -- WHAT, 33
CHILDREN?
>> 33, YUP.
>> AND I ASKED HIM HOW MANY
NANNIES IT TAKES.
FOR NANNIES ON CALL?
>> WHEN NECESSARY, YEAH.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, WHAT DO
YOU CONSIDER USEFUL LIFE SKILLS
THAT WOULD -- THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE YOUR KIDS LEARN?
>> IN PREPARING FOR THE SEGMENT
I THOUGHT ABOUT WHEN I HAVE TO
STOP DOING THINGS FOR MY KIDS
AND WHEN I NEED TO START MAKING
THEM DO THEM.
IT'S NOT A CLEAR LINE, SOME KIDS
ARE READY FOR IT EARLIER, BUT
THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
PARENTS.
AND IN SOME PLACES, I REMEMBER I
TOOK A HOME ACT CLASS IN JUNIOR
HIGH AND I LEARNED HOW TO WRITE
A CHECK, THAT WAS NICE.
I SHOULD'VE TAKEN SHOP CLASS,
BECAUSE I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT TO
DO WITH IT.
>> Greg: WE'VE GOT JOE MACKIE
HERE.
ANY GUY WHOSE JACKET SIFTS UP,
HE KNOW STUFF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: HE'S LIKE KNIGHT
RIDER WITHOUT THE CAR.
>> YEAH.
>> Greg: WHERE IS YOUR TALKING
CAR, JOE?
>> I DON'T NEED A TALKING CAR, I
HAVE MY PHONE FOR THAT.
>> Greg: WHAT ABOUT YOUR KIDS?
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S BETTER TO
ALMOST FREE RANGE THEM LIKE
THEY'RE THEM OUT THERE?
>> YES, AT SOME POINT YOU JUST
HAVE TO LET THEM GO.
I MAKE PANCAKES FOR THEM.
IN THE NEXT YEAR OR SO, YOU
FIGURE IT OUT.
MAKE THEM FOR ME, I WILL
TOLERATE THE MESS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE.
FREE LABOR EVENTUALLY.
>> Greg: WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN I'M OLD?
>> YOU COULD PAY MY KIDS.
>> Greg: THERE YOU GO.
>> BUT THEN THEY GO TO A SAFE
SPACE IN A BUBBLE WHERE THEY GET
IN INTERSECTIONALITY AT DEGREE
AND THEY'VE NEVER DONE THE
LAUNDRY.
BUT NOW I KNOW WHY THE ANTIFA
RIOTS SMELL SO POORLY, THERE'S
NO LAUNDRY GETTING DONE GETTING
DONE.
>> Greg: TYRUS, YOU ARE THE
OTHER PERSON HERE WITH THE
CHILDREN >> ALLEGEDLY.
>> Greg: WHAT WOULD HAPPEN --
[LAUGHS]
IS THERE ANY DANGER THAT YOUR
CHILDREN COULD END UP AS WOKE
ACTIVIST?
>> NOT AT ALL.
I BELIEVE IN THE SEA TURTLE
PARENTING THEORY, CRITICAL SEA
TURTLE THEORY.
YOU HATCH AN EGG, YOU PULL
YOURSELF UP FROM THE SAND.
WELL, GOOD LUCK.
AND THEY KNOW.
THIS IS THE FAULT OR THE GUILT
OF PARENTS WHO WORK HARD.
AND THEY FEEL GUILTY BECAUSE
THEY'VE GOT TO WORK THAT 45 HOUR
SHIFT FOR THE 50 HOUR SHIFT.
THEY TRY TO PROTECT.
THEY WANT TO DO EVERYTHING FOR
THEIR KIDS BECAUSE THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY ARE MAKING UP FOR LOST
TIME.
BUT WHAT YOU WERE MAKING IS A
SPOILED BRAT AND A VICTIM WHO
THEN LEARNS HOW TO MANIPULATE
HIS VERVET DOLL MY FAVORITE
THING TO DO IS -- MOM, I'M
PLAYING A GAME.
MOM, I DON'T WANT TO DO IT.
THE ONES WHO COMPLAIN SAY THEY
NEVER LEARNED LIFE SKILLS.
NO, YOU WERE TAUGHT.
YOU JUST CHOSE NOT TO PAY
ATTENTION BECAUSE HE WERE ON
YOUR PHONE OR ON YOUR GAME OR
WHATEVER IT WAS THAT YOU WANTED
TO DO AT THAT TIME.
OH, GEE, I WISH I WOULD'VE
LEARNED HOW TO DO LAUNDRY.
SHE DID.
YOU JUST DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT.
HOW HARD IS IT TO LEARN LAUNDRY?
>> HERE'S THE DEAL.
MY MOTHER WORKED HARD, BUT SHE
DIDN'T FEEL GUILT.
SHE WAS -- SHE WORKED HARD AND
COULDN'T GO PARTY.
SO IF MY CLOTHES HAD STAYED --
YOU -- YOU FIGURE IT OUT.
YOU CAN READ, WRITE QUESTION
MIKE YOU GO TO SCHOOL FIVE DAYS
A WEEK, SO YOU TO LEARN
SOMETHING.
GOOD LUCK.
AND AT FIRST YOU ARE LIKE -- AND
THEN YOU FIGURE IT OUT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
MADE FUN OF AT SCHOOL.
THERE NEEDS TO BE -- YOU NEED TO
LET THEM FAIL.
WE'LL CALL IT LIFE LESSONS.
LIFE LESSON COMING UP.
NEXT TIME SHE SEES THAT CHAIR,
SHE GOES OH, I DON'T KNOW.
LIFE LESSON.
>> Greg: IT YOU KNOW, AS A KID
IN THE 70s I HAD THAT AMAZING
COMBINATION OF MOTHERHOOD AND
ALCOHOL.
MOM'S WERE GREAT --
BY NOON THEY WOULD HAVE THEIR
LUNCH DRINK.
BUT THE FOOD WOULD GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE SLOPPY.
YOU MIGHT FIND A CIGARETTE IN
THE RAVIOLI.
BUT YOU KNOW, IT WAS GOOD.
MOM WAS PRETTY FUN BY 6:00.
JOE, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> I'M HANGING IN THERE, GREG.
>> Greg: ARE YOU COLD?
>> IT'S LIKE ICICLES COMING
DOWN.
>> Greg: WHAT DID YOU LEARN
FROM THIS RESEARCH, THE SURVEY?
WHAT DISTURBED YOU, WHAT EXCITED
YOU?
>> I DIDN'T LEARN ANYTHING I
DIDN'T ALREADY KNOW BECAUSE I
REMEMBER MY GUIDANCE COUNSELOR
IN COLLEGE ASKED ME WHAT I
WANTED OUT OF COLLEGE AND I SAID
I WANTED A COLLEGE DEGREE.
AND HE GOT KIND OF MAD.
HE SAID WELL, WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO WITH THAT?
AND I SAID DID YOU GO TO COLLEGE
TO BE A GUIDANCE COUNSELOR?
THE WHOLE IDEA IS PREPOSTEROUS.
A LOT OF THE OTHER TEMPS WERE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADS THAT JUST GOT
A TEMP JOB AND THEY WERE GETTING
PAID BY THE COMPANY TO GO TO
COLLEGE TO GET A DEGREE AND A
JOB.
THEY WERE ALREADY DOING.
NONE OF IT MAKES ANY SENSE.
COLLEGE IS FOR MOST AGREES A
PIECE OF PAPER.
IT DOESN'T REALLY TEACH YOU
ANYTHING YOU NEED.
IT JUST SAID HEY, I JUMPED
THROUGH THAT HOOP.
SO IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR COLLEGE
TO GET LIFE SKILLS, THAT'S WHERE
THEY DON'T CALL IT THE REAL
WORLD.
>> Greg: COLLEGE DEGREES ARE
THE ORIGINAL VIRTUE SIGNAL.
TWO CORPORATIONS.
NOW YOU'VE GOT TO GET A GRADUATE
DEGREE, NOW YOU NEED A PhD,
AND YOUR DEBT JUST KEEPS
INCREASING.
IT'S LIKE AN ARMS RACE BETWEEN
OVEREDUCATED OVER CAFFEINATED
PEOPLE.
LET'S GO TO ELVIRA.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S NOT THAT FUNNY, TYRUS.
>> IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT DIDN'T
HAPPEN TO ME.
>> Greg: YOU LOOK STUNNING IN
YOUR BLACK DRESS.
>> THANKS.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
COLLEGE STUDENTS?
THE PEOPLE WITH THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF WISDOM ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
SHOUTING AT US.
THAT IS THE THING THAT DRIVES ME
CRAZY.
I WOULDN'T MIND THEM ADMITTING
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE LIFE SKILLS
IF THEY ALSO ADMITTED, DON'T
TELL US ABOUT WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THIS WORLD.
BUT THIS IGNORANCE OF LIFE
SKILLS WITH THOSE ARROGANT
BELIEF THAT THEY CAN YELL AT US.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY PEER THAT IS
ALWAYS HOW IT IS.
IT IS THE SMALLEST DOG THAT IS
THE LOT IS PARKING.
>> Greg: IS THAT AN ATTACK ON
ME?
[LAUGHTER]
>> TO YOUR POINT, I TOTALLY
AGREE.
THE ISSUE FOR THESE KIDS IS
EITHER BEING ENABLED OR AN ISSUE
OF EXPOSURE.
SO EITHER PARENTS IN THE HOME OR
WHATEVER HOME LIFE THEY HAVE HAS
ENABLED THE FACT THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO ANYTHING OR THEY
WEREN'T EXPOSED TO IT AND THEY
HAD A DIFFERENT KIND OF HOME AND
THEY WEREN'T EXPOSED TO IT IN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS WHICH IS WHY
SCHOOL CHOICE SHOULD COME IN AND
HAVING OTHER TYPES OF EXPOSURE.
WE THINK ABOUT WHAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE FOCUSING ON, RIGHT?
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
PRONOUNS, MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS UNTIL THIS IS
HOW THIS IS OPPRESSIVE.
ALL THESE BOXES THAT HAVE TO BE
CHECKED.
BUT ALONG THE WAY, THEY ARE
PROBABLY MISSING THE KIDS THAT
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO LAUNDRY AND
DON'T WASH THEIR OWN CLOTHES OR
WHATEVER.
THERE'S A WHOLE OTHER TON OF
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES AND IT GOES
UP THROUGH GRADUATE SCHOOL.
I LEARNED MORE IN MY FIRST
HEARING THAT I DID IN MY ENTIRE
CRIMINAL LAW CLASS.
I LEARNED MORE IN ONE HOUR IN A
PRISON THAN I DID AND ALL YEARS
OF LAW SCHOOL.
WHICH IS WHY THINK -- VISITING
PRISONS.
I SAW YOUR EXPRESSION.
>> DID SHE JUST SAY SHE WAS ON
THE PEN?
SPEAK I THINK EVERY JUDGE, EVERY
ATTORNEY, EVERY POLITICIAN, THEY
SHOULD ALL SPEND ONE RIDE ON
THE SUBWAY, ONE HOUR IN PRISON.
IT TAKES A LIFETIME OF THESE
CONCEPTS HE LEARNED IN SCHOOL TO
AMOUNT TO ONE MINUTE IN THE REAL
WORLD.
I DO THINK THE WORLD WOULD BE A
WHOLE DIFFERENT PLACE OF THESE
GUYS THAT MAKE DECISIONS FOR THE
REST OF US WOULD HAVE SOME OF
THAT REAL-WORLD EXPERIENCE.
>> Greg: WHAT YOU ARE SEEN AS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EXPANSE AND
WISDOM SHOULD BE EXPOSING
THEMSELVES TO CHILDREN.
>> [LAUG